the dentists of the United States will long
remember the winter of 1936 for the sudden
unparalleled boom which their business experienced
this sudden rush of patients to have their teeth
attended to was caused by the same news which
caused some 3,200 dentists to crowd one night
into the Grand Ballroom of Manhattan hotel
Commodore and this gentleman is my humble
contribution to humanity and I hope it will be
the means of relieving much unnecessary suffering
to the speaker the assembled dentists give a
rare ovation and up to the platform afterward
searches the entire audience to fight
for copies of a new dental formula and
instructions for its use the results of 20
years research they are now given freely
to mankind next day so sensationally is
hartmann solution hailed in the public
print that its author is embarrassed
dentist upset the public confused
they could easy now awry I've got to hurt you well
try not dirt too much good dentist has got to hurt
dr. Leroy Hartman of Columbia University the
horrors of old-time dentistry indelible in his
memory has devoted patient years of research to
hunting for a painkiller this goal eluded dr.
Hartman until two years ago when he departed from
the Orthodox conception of dental physiology teeth
are composed of an outer layer of hard enamel
an inner mass of softer dentine and a central
nerve pulp which keeps the tooth alive transmits
its sensations to the brain physiologists have
believed that the dentine contains thread like
tendrils extending from the nerve which carry pain
directly from the drill at its point of contact
to focus as a big hot shooting pain in the nerve
dr. Hartman turned from this theory to another
hypothesis but the dentine contains certain fatty
substances called lipoid capable of transmitting
sensation to the nerve if the my voice could be
dissolved temporarily dr. Hartman reason they
would transmit no sensation he compounded a
solution of alcohol and ether to dissolve the
nyborg adding a mole to seal the cavity until
local anesthesia was complete first test
of dr. Hartman's technique were made more
than a year ago in Columbia's free clinic
we'll fix that I won't hurt you open wide
there that didn't hurt did it know how I do
today the public is learning that in many
an adult case Hartman's solution properly
prepared and applied rarely works but that
nevertheless in perhaps fifty percent of
adult cases for one reason or another hartman
solution may not work it certainly doesn't work
on me so while they're professional
committees check and double-check us
dentists warn their clients that hartman
solution is by no means a cure-all best
and most certain news about it is that it
seems to work well on children for children
thanks to hartman solution the dentist drill
should no longer be an instrument of torture
time marches on